hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today's
special edition I'm doing one of my
favorite gigs i'm going to be doing a
review of a website called the here with
the Blessed seed and promote on my
channel so let's go check it out and see
what kind of advice we can give them so
the bless its seed looks like it's black
seed of some sorts a black seed oil
flaxseed oil has been used with healing
remedy for almost every illness no known
side effects okay so health product
anytime we're dealing with a health
product especially you're making bold
claims like this that it can be used as
a healing remedy for almost every
illness people are going to be highly
highly highly skeptical alright there's
a lot of people selling these kinds of
products promising the moon and not
delivering so the first thing I would
try to do is lead in with testimonials
so you want to show people who have used
this product and have had great success
any kind of case studies you can show
any kind of branding that you can put on
there just again to separate yourself
from everybody else who's promising the
world with their products so looking
down this page and see if we have any
examples here I don't see any any kind
of branding so what I'm talking about
here is if you have anything from The
Wall Street Journal or Time magazine or
CNN something to show that people are
talking about the benefits of block seed
or else it's not just you talking about
it here because I've never heard of it
so you want people to have a little bit
more you wanted a little more
credibility so if you could have those
names in there and I'm sure somebody
must have been talking about it if it's
had all these positive effects you have
a quote here from the holy prophet
saying hold on to the use of the Black
Sea foreign Dida has a remedy for
everything except debt so that's great
you definitely want to source that so
you know where can I find that quote if
I wanted to validate it so always put a
source for every code that you put it on
there again it just makes people feel a
little bit more safe secure in what
you're doing for the spacing I probably
you know look at the layout of this page
this is a little bit difficult to read
the size of the text is nice in general
it's easiest to read
the maximum of 100 characters in width
so that's that looks pretty good but you
want to make sure that your space to set
a little bit more so with your
paragraphs always make sure there's an
extra line breaks it's easier to read
and you might want to put a little bit
more bolding in there or lists just to
break it up because this this looks
difficult to read and if it's difficult
to read people won't read it so further
down this looks better with the spacing
and the you know bigger text and the
bolding so you want to make sure you're
doing that higher up here as well so
people will continue to read what you're
doing let's take a quick look at what's
next how it works so that's something I
would be interested in you know how does
it work assuming I've gone past that
homepage you thought it was interesting
okay so some information this is great
that you're against the breaking it up
is a little bit better scrolling down
it's a lot of text so that's going to be
again difficult to read I'd want to
split it up a little bit more with some
pictures the more visually can make it
the better and again make sure your
paragraphs here are spaced out a little
bit more to make it easier to read
people are scanners at the beginning
right I want to quickly scan see if
there's something interesting and if
they like it then they're going to want
to look at it more in more detail so you
want to make it easy for them what's
next research I'm going to want to look
at the research see what kind of
research trees to show that this really
works so here's a picture Natural
Science Museum in London okay here's all
the things that it's good for so aids
anti cancer breast cancer diabetes okay
so promising a huge range again people
are going to be highly skeptical what i
would do here again besides just making
the text a little bit easier again space
these out a little bit better you want
to include links to back these up so
okay you're saying this black seed oil
helps with diabetes and there's a you
know 2002 gifu University in Japan did
this series link to it you know you what
I would want to do is show that I can
click on this link end up on gifu
University and it
show that yes black seed oil can be a
significant value to sufferers of
diabetes too if you're just saying on a
website people aren't going to believe
you but if you link off to the
University or a branded page that people
will associate with and trust more than
yours because you have to develop that
trust if you want them to buy your
product then that will again increase
your credibility and make people believe
what you're saying a little bit more so
for all of these things again people
going to highly skeptical so you want to
link off to show that yes it helps with
colon cancer breast cancer all these
other potential issues that can help
with what's Knox history is quickly
going through the site here so it's been
used for 2,000 years in Western
countries it's known as black suit or
black cumin so this is interesting
because I you know I've heard of black
cumin but I haven't heard of black seed
so if you're selling to a western
country so i'm in north america you may
want to consider using the word cumin
instead of seed a little bit more on the
other pages i have to dig deep here on
this history page before finding out
about the name cumin so you might want
to include that little bit more
elsewhere on the site so people have a
little better understanding of what it
is that you do for more detailed
description of the plant please click
here and this link doesn't work so
there's no link again something you want
to you know make sure all your links are
working especially when you're telling
the click and and there's nothing there
you're using this quote again so there's
a there's a picture here I again try to
reference that to you know where that
that quote is coming from next let's see
what else we have let's click on the
blog maybe there's some new information
here blog okay so the block the blog
goes to a different website so it's
black cumin blogspot CA I would try to
keep your blog on your same domain name
a couple of reason for doing that any
links that you build will help your SEO
for your entire page but also this is
completely different look and feel right
so that this is a totally different
layout I feel like I've left and gone
somewhere else to a different
site not to your own website in your
blog I'd also make sure that you keep it
up to date so this is from july two
thousand twelve right now it's almost
november in 2012 so this hasn't been
updated for a long time I'd either look
at removing a blog or finding a way to
keep it up-to-date with regular updates
so people don't look at and say well
they haven't done anything since July
I'd also definitely look at moving it
over to your own website instead of
having it hosted on on blogspot and
opening up in a different layout so say
I really like everything I'm ready to
buy let's see how can i buy buy it now
let's see what happens when I click here
order black seeds so this is this is
important so you can lose a lot of
people in your bind cycle and what you
want to make sure you do is you keep a
consistent theme so this is still off of
your website to bless a sitcom but it
looks completely different looks like
I've left your website I've gone
somewhere else and so again now I'm
thinking is this a credible site or not
so if you've done all this work in
building up credibility and making
people trust you and believe you you
want to make sure that the look and feel
is exactly the same as the rest of the
website when you get to your buying page
so this looks completely different I
feel like I've left your website and I
have to look up here to make sure that
it is exactly the same website so that
you'll probably lose a lot of people on
your conversion just off this page
they'll come here and bounce so
definitely make sure you put it as kind
of that same layout with the logo
everything else same header looking down
looks like you really focus on UK orders
my eye comes right here I'm looking at
the bottle you know I'm not based in the
UK so it's not necessarily something
would be of interest to me i'm scrolling
down more UK UK prices so how do i buy
here so i guess at the top here says
rest of the world looks really like your
target in the UK audience that's that's
fine if you are maybe even target your
message to talk about everything being
you know uk-based because this actually
will get lost i didn't even see this i
saw the flag I saw the bottle and
completely missed this whole
part here so something to think about if
you're targeting UK orders that's fine
but if you really want to get these guys
then you may want to make that a little
bit more prominent one last thing I just
wanted to quickly mention is the SEO
side of things so what's really
important for SEO at least on the on
on-site work that you can you can modify
yourself is your title tag so looking at
the title tags of these page you can see
here it's you know home how it works
research history and then it's the same
ending for all of them so that they all
say black seed oil specialist a blessed
is a company black seed oil specialist a
black seed company so every page we've
loaded has that same structure a couple
of things here you know you don't want
to have the same title tag on every page
you want to try to split it up to have a
different unique title tags that really
describe what's on each page I know it
also take out the Blessed seed company
from the title tag its name of your
company it's in your domain name so
you're probably going to rank for it
anyway so use more important keywords up
on their things like home how it works
research that's good for for you know
for your navigation menu but for a title
tag you want to be a little bit more
specific so try to put some of your
keywords in there so you know how black
seed oil works or how black cumin oil
works something like that then that
could be a natural search term that
could show up and hopefully drive some
more organic traffic from search engines
to your website I'd also look at the
format so again here you're the next
thing we look at is the the page name so
here we've got history 35 ? history 35
looks like using some kind of content
management system I don't know this
WordPress or something else but you want
to try to make sure that you have your
keywords here in your in the name of the
page so all of these are just going to
be how it works research history so
again whatever your title tag is if it's
if it's going to be you know how black
seed oil works put that here to how
blacks the oil works and that will help
again a little bit with your organic
traffic you got a page here that says
link so let's check that out quickly see
what it's all about
reciprocal links with the Blessed seed
we invite applications reciprocal link
exchange apart from generating mutual
interest the process very efficient in
raising your visibility on search
engines more we linked to one another
better we all do please put this link on
your website so the reciprocal linking
is not does not work nearly as well as
it used to and what Google is really
looking for especially is that it's
editorially given so if they see
something like if they see this page and
that you're just trying to you know
build a whole bunch of links that could
even give you a penalty so i really be
careful about just doing reciprocal
linking and making this so visible
because it could that you have a
negative impact on your site so overall
I you know looks professional enough I
definitely again work on this homepage
first this is where people are going to
land you want to make sure you're
showing something branded something that
that really shows that people are
talking about this not just you talking
about it because you're obviously you
have a vested interest in this but other
people are talking about a brand names
people I know doctors I know you know
newspapers I know and put more quotes
and testimonials on the start to get
people to click past this first page so
hopefully that helps for those are you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below it makes when
I do more of these videos for you and if
you have a thought about this website or
if you have a question about your own
feel free to leave it in the comments
below I always read those and I try to
respond to everybody as soon as I can so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode